For every horror movie that gets a mainstream
audience, there are a dozen that fly under
the radar on their release.
So where can you find all the great horror
movies you've never heard of?
One word: Netflix.
These underrated horror gems never got the
attention they deserved, but now you can revel
in all the terror they have to offer from
the comfort of your living room.
Holidays
Anthology horror has been making a comeback,
and this dark riff on seasonal celebrations
is one of the lesser-known gems in the genre.
Eight different directors, including Kevin
Smith and Gary Shore, contributed a creepy
pint-sized nightmare on a holiday theme.
Like most anthology films, not every one of
these scary stories will hit home, but that's
also part of the charm.
The wildly inventive story lines and diverse
approaches showcased in each of its short
films make Holidays the kind of movie that
has something for everyone.
Hard Candy
Long before she was a well-known name in Hollywood,
Ellen Page was the young star of this immensely
disturbing movie about a 14-year-old girl
who's targeted by a middle-aged predator,
played by Patrick Wilson—only for the predator
to realize he's the hunted, not the hunter.
Page carries the movie to a crazy conclusion
that left no question about her star potential
at the time.
The controversial premise and minuscule budget
made Hard Candy a tough sell when it came
to a traditional release.
But despite being awarded Overlooked Film
of the Year at the 2006 Phoenix Film Critics
Society Awards, the movie has continued to
be a hidden and little-seen gem.
Curve
In this horror flick about a road trip gone
wrong, Julianne Hough stars as Mallory, a
bride-to-be whose car breaks down in the wild
en route to her wedding rehearsal.
When a charming but sadistic hitchhiker enters
the picture, Mallory's last hurrah as a single
girl turns into a fight for survival: she
crashes her car and ends up trapped at the
bottom of a gulch, while the hitchhiker who
survived the crash returns periodically to
taunt her.
Curve should've made a bigger splash than
it did, but it got lost in early 2016 and
went straight to streaming.
However, the theater's loss was Netflix's
gain, so catch it on the streaming service
before it disappears 'round the bend.
The Lazarus Effect
Released in 2015, this movie about a serum
that can bring people back to life was almost
completely overlooked.
On sheer star power alone, The Lazarus Effect
is virtually unmatched in an under-the-radar
horror movie, with Olivia Wilde, Mark Duplass,
Donald Glover, Sarah Bolger, and Evan Peters
all working their magic to elevate a less-than-inspired
concept into legitimately scream-worthy territory.
And while it's true that the script could
be tighter, don't believe the lack of hype
on this one: The Lazarus Effect is a far better
movie than its low rating on Rotten Tomatoes
would suggest.
Netflix definitely knew what it was doing
when it snagged this little story for a screen
adaptation.
Based on a novella from Stephen King's Full
Dark, No Stars anthology, 1922 stars Thomas
Jane as Wilfred James, a farmer living in
rural Nebraska during the period leading up
to the Great Depression.
Money troubles and marital conflict lead Wilfred
to some very dark places—and it just goes
to show that sometimes, getting away with
a crime is much worse than getting caught.
"I'd axed my wife to keep my home.
The only way I'd be leaving it now would be
in chains."
Like many of Stephen King's best works, this
is a character-driven horror, and strong performances
make it a standout—particularly from Jane,
who immerses himself in the role so thoroughly
that it's hard to believe this same miserable,
hay-chewing yokel is the same cosmopolitan
pretty boy from The Sweetest Thing.
"You're never gonna find anyone better than
my brother here.
Here is the greatest and I am sure.
Just look at him, chicks freak on this guy."
Creep
In 2014, filmmaker Patrick Brice set out to
answer the question "What's the worst thing
that could happen from meeting someone on
Craigslist?"
Without spoiling anything, let's just say
that the answer is something really bad.
That's what a videographer discovers when
he goes to the home of Josef—played by Mark
Duplass, who also co-wrote and produced the
movie—for what's supposed to be a documentary
project.
What starts out as the ordinary weirdness
of internet strangers becomes something much
more disturbing.
"Oh that's Peach Fuzz.
That's just Peach Fuzz.
Say hello."
The result is a movie that more than lives
up to its title.
Gerald's Game
With so many blockbusters the big screen in
2017, you might have missed some of the smaller
adaptations of Stephen King's works—including
this one based on the 1992 novel of the same
name.
Gerald's Game centers on a woman named who
ends up trapped, handcuffed to the bed at
her lake house after her husband has a heart
attack.
As she struggles to find a way to escape,
she's visited by a series of entities—some
real, some imagined, and some that seem to
straddle the line between this world and the
next.
"Who are you?"
One of Netflix's original feature films, Gerald's
Game was eagerly anticipated by hardcore King
fans but didn't get the kind of widespread
attention merited by its creativity and star
power.
Despite the obvious challenges of holding
down an entire two-hour film on her own, actress
Carla Gugino keeps it riveting, making this
the finest horror movie set almost entirely
on a bed since, well, maybe ever.
Unless you count Bed of the Dead.
A Dark Song
This Irish independent horror movie flew under
the radar when it released in 2017, but the
handful of film buffs who did see it were
impressed—and with good reason.
A Dark Song centers on a grieving mother who
hires an occultist to guide her through a
complex, months-long rite at a remote home
in the Welsh countryside.
Despite a teensy budget and a very green director
at its helm, A Dark Song boasts incredible
production values and phenomenal sound work
that subverts the usual tried-and-true horror
film tropes.
Instead, the film revels in the slow burn
and deliberately draws out the tension.
In the end, this entry is a deep, dark, and
gorgeously acted meditation on loss that builds
into a harrowing and unexpected climax.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!